Так було -
а так стало.
Панельний мікрорайон на півдні Потсдама перетворюється на справжнє місто-сад.
Це типова забудова часів НДР.
Свого часу це було символом турботи "партії і уряду" про трудящих -
панельні, блочні та інші серійні будинки, які спотворили вигляд більшості міст
як в колишньому Радянському Союзі, так і в колишній Східні  й Німеччині.
У соціалістичні часи квартири в таких будинках були великим дефіцитом.
Але коли соціалізм закінчився, населення у східнонімецьких містах
почало стрімко скорочуватися - люди переїжджали на Захід.
Тож, попит на комірки в панельних будинках став падати.
Цьому потсдамському мікрорайону Древіц з близько п'ятьма тисячами мешканців пощастило.
Тут успішно реалізують концепцію міста-саду.
Мета проекту - не просто відремонтувати житлові будинки,
але й осучаснити цілий мікрорайон та звести до нуля викиди парникових газів у кварталі
за рахунок переходу на енергію з відновлюваних джерел,
а також створення вільної від автотранспорту зони.
Це справді складно втілити.
Але завдяки тому, що вдалося суттєво скоротити проїзний транспорт,
у нас тепер вдвічі менше машин.
Тобто залишився, по суті, лише автотранспорт місцевих мешканців,
чужі тут не гасають.
Мешканці сприймають це позитивно.
Разом з тим ми спостерігаємо, що кількість особистого транспорту скорочується.
Трамвай у центр міста ходить кожні десять хвилин.
Замість проїжджої частини - сквер і дитячі майданчики.
Стандартні фасади соціалістичних часів не впізнати.
Цей пілотний проект вважається унікальним для всієї федеральної землі Бранденбург.
У рамках ухваленої в 1972 році державної програми житлового будівництва
у НДР до 1990 року з'явилося майже два мільйони квартир у панельних будинках.
Термін їхньої експлуатації - 50 років.
Тож, з плином часу постало питання: що краще - модернізувати їх чи просто знести?
Прагматичні німці дивляться, що економічніше, враховують попит і ціну реконструкції.
У східнонімецьких містах, населення яких скорочується,
місцеві "хрущівки" дешевше просто знести.
Натомість там, де попит є, санація зазвичай обходиться на третину дешевше,
аніж їхнє знесення та будівництво нових.
Економічно найкращий варіант! Плюс - це ж надбання нації!
Не можна просто так брати і зносити будинки і будувати щось нове:
ані з точки зору економіки, ані з точки зору етики.
Адже це побудовано людьми, це частина історії,
люди тут цілі життя проживали, тут виростали покоління.
Ви тільки уявіть собі - ви приїжджаєте в місце,
де ви народилися і виросли - а його раптом немає! Це ж жахіття!
Важлива запорука реалізації таких проектів -
постійний діалог з місцевими жителями про майбутнє району.
На стадії планування відбулися десятки дискусій про те,
яким буде мікрорайон і скільки це коштуватиме.
Тим, кому довелося залишати квартири на час капітального ремонту,
влада оплатила переїзд в тимчасове житло - і назад.
Знадобилося багато перемовин, умовлянь.
А потім треба було просто брати і показувати,
що якості життя в іншій формі не можна досягти, залишивши парковку біля входу.
Ми створили показовий мікрорайон з гарною перспективою на майбутнє.
Це переконало багатьох людей погодитися на підтримку проекту.
Це остання вільна квартира у відремонтованому будинку -
найближчим часом сюди в'їде подружня пара.
Санація квадратного метра у таких будинках коштує від 500 євро.
Їх приводять до суворих у Німеччині норм енергоефективності,
ізолюючи заново фасади та міняючи дахи та вікна.
Фінансують це в основному на кошти приватних власників або інвесторів
з доплатами від держави на модернізацію житла.
Мистецтво у тому, щоб і після санації житло залишалося доступним.
Найбільша проблема в тому, що люди, яким потрібні такі квартири, не мають на них грошей.
Вони не можуть платити оренду, тому що ремонт відносно дорогий.
А тут ми можемо запропонувати доступну оренду в п'ять з половиною євро за квадратний метр.
Це значно нижче від середньої ціни у Потсдамі.
Реконструкція мікрорайону ще не завершена.
Але вже тепер Древіц, який мав імідж соціально неблагополучного району,
залишив останнє місце в рейтингу найбільш непопулярних мікрорайонів Потсдама.